the whole world is waiting for the kovid
19 vaccine
and several things are coming in the
mind first of all
the effectiveness the side effects
and the cost of this vaccine and lastly
when this vaccine would be available in
the market according to world health
organization
there are 23 vaccines or candidate
vaccines
which are in several phases of clinical
trial among them
one of the vaccine chad ox ncof19
has to bleed and this vaccine was
designed by the researchers
in oxford university their initial
finding
is now released in the medical journal
lancet
and this assess the safety and the
immunogenicity of the chadwicks in cov19
vaccine
and in this video we'll talk about how
this particular vaccine works
the biology behind it how safe is this
vaccine
and when this vaccine is coming to the
market
and lastly we're going to talk about the
unanswered question
about this vaccine so let's just have a
quick
bite about all of these questions
so first of all how does this vaccine
works
simply it works by activating our
humeral
and cell mediated immune response it
augments
both these kind of immune responses how
safe is this vaccine
it turns out based on the clinical
results it's pretty much
safe but these results are restricted to
a small population
the results from phase 3 clinical trial
on phase 2 clinical trial are yet
pending
so we can't say with high confidence yet
when the vaccine is released in the
market if
everything goes right the higher
official said it could be released at
the end of this year
so we are still quite far away
now this vaccine generation is a
stepwise fashion
it's not instantaneous so if you're
thinking that taking a market back
you're going to the market and get
grabbed that vaccine
you are wrong because there are
several phases there is phase 1 trial
phase 2
phase 3 trial and at the end of the
phase 3 trial there could be fda
approval
and lastly it could be launched into the
market so
it's a very long process
but the good part is after the phase one
trial
there was quite a lot of hope that is
evoked in the scientific community
based on the performance of these
vaccine in small population
so let me talk about a little bit on
clinical trials
so there is pre-clinical phase where the
vaccine
is applied on rodent and
primate model such as monkey or mouse
and if everything goes
correctly and this vaccine turns out to
be effective
then it would be applied on small
population of humans
so the phase one trial includes 20 to
80 participants volunteers rather
and then in phase 3 clinical trial more
than 1 000
individual would be tested for the
effectiveness of the vaccine if
everything turns out to be correct the
effectiveness is high
and the efficacy is good
then these vaccine would be released in
the market
and would gain a fda approval
even after the vaccine is released in
the market there would be a post
release survey that is a phase four
trial
and in the phased for trial the data is
accumulated for safety effectiveness
efficacy etc
if the vaccine turns out to be safe
effective then this vaccine is continued
in the market
so it's a very long process let us see
which phase we are in actually we are in
the phase
1 trial so in order to understand how
this vaccine work we need to understand
how coronavirus
affects our body the biology behind it
so everybody is familiar with the
coronavirus pandemic right
so let me tell you the coronavirus is
nothing but a
rna virus which is a relative to the
influenza virus or a natural flu virus
so it has envelope it has spike proteins
it has other proteins such as e proteins
m proteins etc
now the spike proteins help the virus
to get inside the cell by interacting
with a receptor present in the surface
of the cell
and it allows the virus to be
endocytosed or taken in
by the cell and that is how it gets the
entry inside our body
now these spike proteins are proteins
so their blueprint is in the viral
genome or the viral gene
scientists took advantage of this
phenomena
and they have done a very clever
approach
so now they have taken
advantage of the fact that the virus use
this receptor to get
in now whenever the virus tries to get
in our body also try
to make antibodies and prevent this
virus to get
in if the antibody coats the virus it
cannot interact with the
cell surface receptor and as a result
the virus cannot
get in so
the scientists did a very nice thing
they took
a adenovirus the adenovirus is not
harmful to human at all
but they could be excellent gene
delivery system
so they took the spike protein gene and
cloned it inside the adenoviral vector
now adenovirus vector is very efficient
in terms of
affecting a mammalian cell so they would
grow this adenovirus
inside a mammalian cell culture increase
the number
and once the number reached some around
5 into 10 to the per 10 viral particles
they would inject that
viral particle intramuscularly into a
patient
basically this is the vaccine
so the adenovirus would enter the
cells of the human via specific
receptors
and inside the cell of inside the host
cell it would
in it would give rise to the spike
protein
so first of all the spike protein mrna
would be produced it would be
transported out to this
cytoplasm and the spike protein would be
produced
this spike protein is the molecular
signature for this covid19 virus
so this spike protein is pretty harmful
and at least it's a signature for the
virus
so what would be so beneficial if these
signatures would be expressed in the
cell
now these signatures can be secreted out
of the cell the benefit of this
signature
is the immune system would treat them as
an immunogen or an
antigen so they would
elicit an immune response against them
in the in terms of making antibody
so the body would generate antibody
against these
against these antigens and there is a
benefit
of generating the antibody because next
time
when the covid virus would itself attack
then the body is prepared for the combat
way more in order to understand this
portion better we need to understand the
biology
in little bit more details so let us
understand
how primary and secondary immune
response work
let's say you are affected by any kind
of pathogen any kind of virus
so your body tries to fight back within
10 days to 20 days there would be
antibody production in your body against
that particular antigen
and that is how our body is trying to
fight back this
infection but there is a big problem
body has no clue about any infection
right
for body these viruses or this pathogen
might be new because body might not be
experienced them previously so body
takes quite a lot of time to recognize
them
and then mount an immune response so it
takes almost
10 to 14 days to generate these
antibodies
and then in the second exposure it is
way quicker
but there is a fundamental problem
now when the body is affected by these
kind of viruses
these viruses grow very rapidly
before even the body can generate the
antibody
in a significant quantity the virus
would grow
and they would replicate and they would
increase their number
to an extent that body cannot handle it
so body what is immune system is now
overloaded
and the game is over the vaccine works
taking account of these things now
imagine if you train your immune system
cells
the armies of the immune system such as
t cell or b cell
by telling them that this
is the identification mark of the threat
that means the spike protein is the
identification mark of the threat
and this is how the kovid 19 virus look
like
then our immune system would be more
efficient in terms of recognize them and
they would be
prepared by producing the antibodies
beforehand right now
when the kovid virus really affects the
body
then already our body has the remedy
they have the antibody ready
they can immediately engage and
neutralize the virus
and that is how the response could be
augmented and the response could be fast
this is how the vaccine works i'll come
to the data i'll come to
the exact experiments but before that
let me tell you the interesting fact
about this vaccine
not only it triggers the body or the
immune system to
produce antibodies but also this
particular vaccine
triggers t cell responses which is a
part of our cell mediated
immunity if you want to learn more about
cell mediated immunity
the link is in the description or the
link is in the i button
now let me tell you the overall
experimental framework that they have
used so they have
generated the vaccine and they have
injected the vaccine which is nothing
but adenoviral particles
5 into 10 to the power 10 adenoviral
particles are
injected intramuscularly then
blood samples are collected from these
vaccination candidates or the
vaccination volunteers
in several intervals intervals and
the development of immune response was
checked by elisa assay so let us look at
how elisa work to understand the data
so the antigen which is derived from
covid19 which is
known the spike protein is coated on the
well of these microtiter plates
now the patient sample is provided in
these wells expected
that the patient sample might have the
antibody against this virus right
so if the patient sample have the
antibody
while putting a secondary antibody we
should get a
colored reaction because the secondary
antibody binds to the primary antibody
and if and only if the
antibody the primary antibody is present
then the secondary antibody can work
so a color reaction would be developed
and this color reaction would tell us
that the immune
response is on in the body
so the color reaction is the key for
detecting
detecting the immune response
now let me tell you the data so this
data
tells us how the immune response
is triggered over time in the x-axis you
can say
see the days after vaccination and in
the
y-axis you can see the immunogenicity or
the immune response
in terms of elisa units so you can see
the
increasing trend right so the reactivity
inside the elisa is increased that means
more and more antibody was
generated and that's why you get more
elisa
response right and this response is
quite comparable
to the kovid patient sample but let me
tell you this response is not dropping
off after a few days that's a very good
part of it that's the most positive part
of this particular
vaccine and this kind of response is
very comparable
to a response which is shown by the
convalescent plasma of a
patient in short or in simplicity
these kind of response is pretty much
comparable to the response that is
happening inside the patient's body
but the biggest question is if
the patient is already showing an immune
response then why they are dying
because the whole point is time
if these vaccine is not there
the immune system takes quite a lot of
time to generate these antibodies by
that time the
game should be over so the vaccine
helps to fight the virus by already
producing the antibodies
now coming to the side effects so here
is a panel of side effects that can
affect by these by the administration of
this vaccine
so you can see the fever generation is
way
less right so there is this is day since
the
vaccination and you can see the fever is
only generated in
one or two day and after that it falls
off though there is a little bit of
fatigue
chills and muscle ache but this is all
fine this is this turns out to be pretty
safe because any vaccine have a mild
side effect
but there is no major side effect which
is recorded
and that is the point of hope but
this vaccine yet has to uh
go through the third phase of clinical
trial and ultimately the fd approval
so the journey of thousand mile begin
with a single step
and we have taken few steps the
researchers have taken
few step towards generation of these
vaccine
so it's always a good thing now we
should
keep our hope and fingers crossed till
the vaccine is there
but the vaccine is not available
tomorrow in the market
so that is why we need to still use our
mask
sanitizer and we have to ensure that
social distancing is maintained
all of these things would help us to
fight against
this virus so if you like this video
please share it with
uh your friends students
anyone because people need to know about
how this vaccine work
so if you like this video don't forget
to subscribe to my channel and please
share this video in social media